and I want to focus now Chris on those
those two penalties that fueled the
final two scoring drives for the Green
Bay Packers same guy Trey flowers
Alliance same blocker David Bakhtiari
the Packers same call made by the same
person the umpire remember the umpire
used to be in that scrum behind the line
of scrimmage facing the quarterback now
he is back where the referee is so he
sees this all unfold in front of him and
he believes he saw illegal hands to the
face now there was kind of a little blow
to the head there but I don't think that
was enough that the decision I believe
came from that there with the hand up
under the neck yeah and it wasn't quite
in the neck in the face area and it
happened twice and you know Trey flowers
apparently they said during the
broadcast has never been called for that
in his entire career what do you make it
out when you see it well what I make is
you know it's dangerously close you know
it's in that like collar the horse
collar area there it's hard to see I
just wish this more than anything you
know and David Baca tre what else also
helped I don't think he was doing this
intentionally but the fact that he was
kind of bent back and his neck was bent
back as well it almost made it look a
little bit more like it was on the neck
at that point but I just wish in some of
these big moments right now and because
I said this earlier on radio right
his bakhtiari selling that no not his
technique I know and he feels a hand up
here does he you know is that who I arm
it's broken I mean do you embellish some
to make it look if he did it was the
game ball right yeah I don't think he
was intentionally doing that I mean I
think he had a really strong man that
had a hold of them up here and you know
that's gonna make your body and that go
in that direction like that but I think
the big point for me more than anything
is I just wish that referees in the NFL
right now would kind of go by the Credo
especially here late in games of just
let the guys play let's not over
officiate if it's close don't throw the
flag I just wish we would go like that
right now I feel like why if it's a foul
it's a foul well then I don't I don't
like the idea that we apply a different
standard at different times of the game
well okay fine then let's go just do it
the whole game okay
it because because it that was not a
foul and there being a little - you know
what do I want to see overcautious over
a fishiest or whatever you know I mean
they are all right Marv levy and I think
that that is more or not something I
wish the referees would just back off a
little bit it's not an easy job gosh
they're watching a lot they're watching
some of the most explosive strong people
on our planet go at it in a scrum and
they're trying to watch a lot of
different things but either way those
were not good calls but this is why they
need to have an official who is part of
the crew who is watching what we see and
bridging the gap between HD 4k whatever
the next technology is that I probably
should know about but don't and what the
people on the field are trying to
process in real-time full-speed with the
naked eye while they're trying not to
get trampled that's the problem the NFL
refuses to acknowledge and Chris my hope
is and and there is a silver lining here
because that stuff went down last night
right before the quarterly League
meeting yeah and hopefully that'll be
all the discussion today and the buzz
and someone will commit the funds
necessary to having another member of
the officiating crew who is there to see
what we see and talk to the officials on
the field as a member of the crew not
part of replay right as a member of the
crew who sees what we see and says pick
up the flag or drop the flag it would
have avoided the Rams Saints outcome it
could have avoided what happened last
night if that video official sees that
tre flowers didn't have his hand up high
enough and that person is an equal
member of the officiating crew and just
there's this arrogance that the
officials have that you can only know
what's going on if you're down there on
the field and I think that's baloney a
lot of times it's better to have the
perspective that we have to understand
what happened ultimately that's all that
matters
it doesn't matter what you see when
you're on the field because the people
at home don't see that they see what's
on TV and that's what needs to mesh
together and the sooner they bridge that
gap the sooner we quit complaining about
bad officiate well I'm not so sure it
won't go that way Mike I mean I think
that you are onto something I know
you've been banging this drum since last
offseason and I'm
I'm you might be right on this I mean
this might be the way to go if they can
you know a little like we saw you want
like a little like we saw in the Kansas
City game where the referee put his ear
up and I know we think or we're pretty
sure we're assuming he was listening to
our River on you want that but somebody
upstairs in the booth actually in the
stadium like you're saying a part of the
crew and they can listen and go hey guys
I'm watching the replay right now it
wasn't it wasn't in the neck or the head
let's pick it up and just move on it's
fourth down whatever it may be I hear
you and I think that might be after way
to go and the NFL has got to stop
you know penny-pinching on some of these
things yeah and really that's what it
comes down to allocating the funds
necessary to make this happen and when
you are going to make millions if not
billions from legalized gambling as it
continues to spread you have an
incentive to get these calls right
because if the officiating problem
becomes big enough and if enough people
have their hard-earned cash at risk
based upon the whims of whoever happens
to be on the field dropping flags or not
dropping flags
that's when Congress starts to get
involved and that's when people start to
wonder is there something fishy going on
is there's something that needs to be
investigated right you know that gets it
let me make one other point because we
want to move on from the officiating at
least for now there needs to be greater
transparency from the NFL it can't just
be a pool report after the game Chris
they need somebody who can come on this
show who can go on every show and
explain these things own the mistakes
when the mistakes happen explain for
example when there's an illegal hit on a
defenseless receiver and booger
mcfarland it complains for five minutes
that the guy was just trying to catch
the ball the defensive player was just
trying to catch the ball yeah you need
to be able to have that person who comes
on and says it does not matter right
that this is the rule that we've adopted
10 years ago to protect defenseless
receivers and even if you don't mean to
do it you still are responsible for that
15-yard penalty if you hit the receiver
in the head/neck area well and they used
to kind of have it in women Mike Pereira
they had it kind of in Dean Blandino
they don't have it an hour of Iran I
don't even think they try to have au
revoir on to it they need someone whose
job is only to be that spokesperson who
would come on and explain to us today
wouldn't it be great to come out of the
gates here is the NFL whatever the title
would be
explain to us what happened in those
moments wouldn't that be great if they
had someone who could do it and do it
well and put these issues to rest before
they become a fire strike I mean two
great ideas about you today I'm with you
there too I think it would it would
silence the critics and of course you
know tell us more about the league and
what's going on and make it a little bit
more accountable I'm totally with you
there and at least kill the conspiracy
theories because when there is no
transparency here's what happens I got a
text last night from somebody connected
to the league saying is is the NFL still
trying to get Matt Patricia for the
Roger Goodell clown nose shirt that he
wore off of the plane at Super Bowl 51 I
mean it's a ridiculous notion right but
when but but when you look at and say
what the hell's going on it invites that
if you don't have transparency and a
good explanation
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports